churches and schools are on alert in
Wisconsin after a man allegedly
threatened to use a large cache of
weapons on public officials police
released a video of 32 year-old Joseph
jackubowski mailing an anti-government
anti religion manifested to president
Trump David Pegg no is outside the gun
shop in Janesville Wisconsin where the
suspect allegedly stole a bunch of
weapons David good morning
Nour good morning police believe Joseph
jackubowski broke into the Armageddon
gun store here on the same day he mailed
that manifesto to President Trump last
week and in the manifesto the local
sheriff says jackubowski made it clear
he does not like people in power from
the president to law enforcement in fact
when he mailed the manifesto it was one
of his friends who recorded this video
at the post office
[Music]
when Joseph jackubowski mailed his one
hundred and sixty-one page manifesto to
President Trump on Tuesday he brought
witnesses to mark the occasion three
hours later police say jackubowski broke
into the Armageddon gun shop and stole
16 high-end rifles and handguns they
found his abandoned and burned car a
short distance away today
so remember this face about 150 local
state and federal officers are involved
in the manhunt this weekend they
searched homes in Janesville but came up
empty please call even if your
information you may not think is
important we may find that it is
important investigators suspect
Jakubowski has been highly agitated
recently over political issues basically
he's angry at all government officials
whether it's the president or whether
it's local officials or whether it's law
enforcement they say they don't know of
any specific threats but schools were
closed on Friday and police stepped up
patrols around churches on Sunday one
canceled Palm Sunday services
court records show Jakubowski has dozens
of convictions including battery
domestic abuse bail-jumping drug
possession and resisting an officer
there was one specific case where
he attempted to disarm a police officer
and for that crime he was sent to prison
police are urging the public not to
approach him if they see him and to call
911 I hope this gets resolved quickly
and I say prayers for our community our
nation and for him police believed
jackubowski has a bulletproof vest and a
helmet with him there were two reported
sightings in this area yesterday but
nothing panned out that friend at the
post office who recorded that video is
apparently cooperating with law
enforcement and Charlie the Speaker of
the House Paul Ryan a notable public
official he is from this area and there
has been an increased police presence at
his local office here David thank you